you
we are ready to play in the Cobian
tournament 53 players at the start one
minute
Ches 30 minutes of 1-minute chess ah
let's see if we could grab a tempo
against their Queen soon
the b5 and I'm just gonna push and maybe
push again let's get here and target f2
you gotta take my knight whoa
let's try this sneaky huh it's a sneaky
move with Knight g4 let's take this
Queen g5 I've night here
really
let's interfere with the Queen don't let
her come to this square so easily
oh I gotta get that off as soon as
possible hang on not so fast though I've
made that mistake before don't let it
happen again
I just want to take on h2 and then here
isn't this running it to mate soon the
knight has to block and stuff because I
have g1 covered it's take and I don't
know here 22 seconds Knight takes pawn
that's a fork and they're probably gonna
resign they resigned back to tournament
hurry boom always promote to a queen
look at how fast that was did I learn or
what did I learn how to change that
setting or what the pieces aren't going
so smooth they're kind of and they're
dragging a little bit there he goes
complaining again Oh dark square bishop
huh um here I guess in-betweener oh yeah
now we're gonna plant my bishop right on
e5
it's a beautiful square let's tie it in
with the rook on b8 I don't want a
castle so on the rook double I playoff
six
I want my king on e7 he needs to be
really careful there we go let's just
inch my way up I want to break down that
night push you know let's do this just
play on this side you're gonna push here
try to get into f7 play g5 stop Knight
f4 I was gonna play that if they look to
go on to the G file I could have taken
on each three shouldn't be so much an
issue they're in a pin now on the H file
let's take get a passed pawn keep
pushing and I guess I'm go here
time I guess here I have h7 covered
there we go
no mates hmm meetin once right yeah Adam
they were way down in time though okay
five four four four
a lot of fours sixty two players what
about ten more entered okay
plenty of time cycle okay maybe we shoot
for a king's indian set up
what are these moves creeper
creepy-crawler variation let's throw a
punch at the queen let's break up in
this position now it's a queen who
they're not gonna move the queen huh
interesting
Oh Knight here is gonna hurt me isn't it
yikes
okay mass exchanges
they wouldn't do that okay now maybe
breakdown yeah let's do that now that I
have pressure here scoop that pond up
it's not fun but I have to stop this and
then crashing through
I need my Kings help I'd be fine with
the night trade oh okay well they don't
have this push now that their King is
there and let's get him out of there
stop Knight here oh you sneaky guy very
sneaky oh they missed that I was on the
rook helpful say the least
okay back to tournament nine eight eight
eight yeah their King was turning into
pac-man they're hunting down my a pond
out of nowhere all right make a move
efore all right what do we call this
this the center counter is that what
they call it that's how I first knew it
the center coner
just drop your deep on be more concerned
about your knife being pinned and drop
your deep on all right I have the bishop
pair let's start let's let the dark
square Bishop be a pest let black feel
the dark square Bishop here we go he's
in a pin we're gonna look to pile up
Queen f3 no it's so fast you know move
that Jeep on there we go now we're
cooking okay take with the pawn maybe
play on the h-file I could grab this guy
let's do it
you can't go too far let's return here
look for me got it back to tournament
that was pretty quick 13 12 9 9 who let
them out his in
first speedster is on my heels terminal
is on onboard what are you trying to say
just play chess quit it with the
commentary just play chess um I don't
know secure my bishop don't like how I'm
playing this let's expand on the
queenside
I don't think I net anything by
maintaining by releasing that tension
let's get it right Oh
lining up sneaky stuff there now this
now this is an issue maybe I should have
done that one move sooner huh yeah as
soon as that Knight moved and there
wasn't defense to the bishop I should
have captured here so now this is
clearly getting broken down domino
effect secure here f4 is under control I
don't want to play g4 I could win a
piece but it's a little scary maybe now
I have this idea trap the night I know
that Bishop g4 isn't really an issue
this is even a possibility it's probably
simpler c5 maybe I take no let's go here
push on the bishop tonight every piece
is hanging let's keep pressure on the
bishop I lied about the bishop hanging
it's not my Queens trap though that's
not I don't know what I'm doing I'm
gonna lose on time though if I don't
hurry no no okay
no take with the rook I'll be doing on
the clock let me get that move in there
tricky Knight to the rescue he does it
again back at it again with the forks
I'm sorry I won't let that happen again
I won't do that again
maybe I will
I might not be able to shake it I might
not be able to shake that one off tricky
night back at it again with the fork all
right we are at 1716 1613 mighty dog and
who let them out is there oh all right H
pawn
let's give him a name oh wow
living really dangerous look at this
this King has gone bonkers they should
here well that's gonna be deadly not
quite maybe at the end I win the bishop
yeah thought it's still gonna be tricky
they're gonna grab on g2
I don't know it's a really wait a really
weird way to activate your rook
yikes
hmm we're covered all right man yeah
not cool man not cool I have to run over
here man awful
they're in the think tank a little bit
ha
their queen is tied down man what's that
about doing time burners they're doing
time burners ah back to tournament
what did I I probably had Nate there too
mmm okay that's a big setback a really
big one we're not at the halfway point
yet but uh what did I let happen in that
one I let them Queen my bishop was
kicked off of defending that key square
that key queening square how could I
have better converted that I should have
should have mated that King Queens I
should have not traded Queens for one
how did I allow that keep the Queens on
the board next time their King was
running for his life
and you traded Queens shame on you you
deserve to lose that you deserve to lose
that let's keep the bishop and drop your
pawn okay here we get the b-pawn back
maybe mm-hmm I guess we are gonna get
this guy back to rooks for the Queen not
sure what this is doing stops the rook
from doing what I don't know I can't
move my rook from FA what's that
ship up - what is he up to Paul that was
a almost a badmouth slip uh-oh
Fischer can't move I should have done
that one move sooner got a piece now get
a fast move in there
all right here should be fine and
they're down in time 29:24 21 18 hmm do
I have to consider berserk Inge I don't
feel confident with how slow the pieces
are moving no I think it's still too
early I may have to do that not really a
fan of berserk unless it's like an
all-out berserk I don't know we'll just
take them they're gonna get a nice
Center I understand and they're gonna
maybe win this pawn um the knight could
still jump in there mm-hmm they're
prepping that advance I'm gonna have to
find new homes for my pieces soon about
f5 let's do it on tree oh stop Bishop f3
what about Queen g5 don't forget about
that square there you go I mean take c3
on pond takes get out of there
we're looking for mate on f2 can't be
stopped the night has to go here but it
still can't be stopped on the next move
though bishop can't even move oh the
King has to run here they should resign
all right time to resign oh it's that
move they resigned back to term and
pretty quick 29 24 21 2014 minutes and
change okay
efore deform and let's let's an invite
the f-pawn to the game they're trying to
establish a strong point on e5 let's go
over here and hunt down my bishop the
knight h5 let's point some pieces at
their king
yikes held together by its red yep
you're not gonna play g5 crazy I was
definitely gonna sack if you did that
careful now
you know the dark square bishop and
guess where your king and queen are hang
on give me that pawn Knight g5 give me
the dark square Bishop mm-hmm hey Knight
you're not doing over anything over
there on c3 join the attack on the Kings
side that's where you have a space
advantage bishop f8 if if I played
Knight f4 keep the Queen's on the board
pinpoint f7 don't forget about h7 got
mate they have to give up their queen
rook e8 Queen e7 rook takes f7 they
resigned back to tournament thirty-one
we had a draw he's not on fire the two
that are ahead of me are not on fire 31
26 24 12 minutes in change all right
this is not one of the top two guys
I don't know in advance ah the pieces
are really going slow
yikes
okay let's take here and then they're up
in the night I'm a light square bishop
gonna take on b2 like a castle and
defend that let's kick the rook away and
now challenge this night take care of
pawn takes they can't counsel so easily
now we're prepping this advance the
knight cannot get to this square c5 or
f8
huh I'm just gonna take and now enter
with the Queen oh my goodness Bishop h6
don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it yes oh I was hoping I was
definitely hoping King you don't want to
be here
oh here
rook up and over okay now I could cross
finally night I need your help
huh get here oh this is a terrible game
terrible game I'm in pins now and
everything I'm still in pins I'm down on
clock they could take that pun time and
time again nine seconds I just want to
trade yes back to tournament that was so
ugly Bishop h6 would have crunched me ah
31 28 28
10 minutes 10 seconds hmm
and I don't have the confidence in my
mouse mmm all right only 3 points back
this guy's berserk and me already
maybe I should have preserved back I
have that Moo
let's just get my bishop to a safe
square all right now we'll take take
that night he was free I was ready to
drop my queen let's not do that
got a queen trade in there coming out
right on the clock didn't point that
pawn my rook was hit I almost didn't see
that I'm not sure what that move is
doing you could also land a fork don't
forget about that let's improve the King
position and take here and then get
these guys going huh wish that King away
going they don't have any time back to
tournament 32 got a lead and I'm on fire
32 32 28 less than 9 crap mikaze oh
that's a cool name
I like this creative name their grandma
Kazi all right I'm gonna take care ok
push get a fork still do this no I can
still get that in this has to be pretty
uncomfortable it's Bishop g4 coming now
to play off three ok let's cancel Queen
side you have both rooks really doing a
good job
oh let's take care
by night in there stop this night from
doing anything okay
simplified quite a bit
Oh actually the Queen's have to come off
the board and where do I want my knight
to be I guess that five is a good spot
huh there goes my night oh he lives King
here first I should have played rook
here okay I think I'm okay with this
trade because they have a lot of weak
pawns in fact all their pawns are weak
this is also a good square I'm with in
checking distance let's just take him
out pre move pretty quick here I don't
know probably wasn't the best approach
okay hmm let's defend that pawn okay
that was really helpful
now we're gonna take ooh and they
resigned back determine 36 34 31 30 who
two points ahead and I'm still on fire
this is a near port one and let's open
this up maybe get Bishop f4 against the
Queen I could do this 'if i could take
the knight get still Oh Knight takes
Knight and then the follow-up whoops
there goes a piece not cool no I got to
keep it close somehow d5 e5
all right throw my knight in here yikes
just want to keep some pieces on the
board okay
the more we shuffle the better off I am
that's what that's what this position
has come to uh-huh
finally mass exchanges I guess and let's
still keep my tricky night around get my
King towards the center
yikes have they moved I didn't see that
they moved there hmm okay I have to
trade now are we doing on the clock we
have a slight edge a slight edge on the
clock might be tricky for them actually
yeah I think it'll be a little bit
tricky oh it's definitely tricky now
Bishop takes just want a Queen trade
block okay I should
this man what how about you just play a
game where you actually don't drop your
minor piece within the first 10 moves
you know you know why you just think for
an extra second or two early on instead
of dropping a piece and then going into
mouse tactics you know
okay okay now you belong on c4 get there
that's security five in case they're
excited about pushing my pieces around
Bishop here hmm how to recapture I guess
here oh that's a super valuable piece
dark square Bishop is gone there Knight
is getting kicked around got this
alright
take looking to undermine the knight
next uh-oh problem on c3 this bishop is
gonna come to life soon or just be dead
better or just be dead and I don't know
that's got to put the fear right in you
a little bit huh
that's alright your Knights unprotected
dark squares are broken down pile up on
the pinned piece make them feel the pain
there we go that's a check that's a
passed pawn and this square covered I
guess here clean here
feels right let's do it and you know
let's just take here
I think things really simple they
resigned back determine I'd good
coordination they're two minutes left
four-point lead yiiikes we might get
paired up is he playing we're gonna get
paired up I might have to no no Frey at
the end he just finished uh-oh are we
gonna get paired up or not a minute
forty here it is for all the marbles the
Carroll Khan mainline now you know it's
serious playing the main line okay so I
got the bishop pair yay for me right
let's see what you could do with it okay
don't get made it now whatever you do
don't get made it um you're not moving
not sure how I feel about that knight
move maybe kick the Queen away clean
trade Queen trade it is I like where my
bishops stand he's a really good piece
bishop check they should can test the
file they're gonna move towards the
center I need to get my King active keep
going oh no you just dropped g2 you
idiot ah
not cool that was an important pawn a
very important pun wait can I get that
bishop I got this pawn though
oh they got that how did they rescue
their bishop though what an interesting
uh endgame a5 I have this Wow
what a wild one this is turning out to
be huh
you're gone
I'm gonna take here no I don't want to
do that no they're down on time oh the
tournament's over as well oh man ah what
a crazy end game that was with the two
bishops for both of us that was pretty
wild and good game to let them out that
was pretty nuts
okay 44 44 I won on tiebreak 36 36 35
all right
don't know if I'm sneaking everybody in
there when I go through these pages but
this is as far down as I could go all
right let's see page 2 3 4 there we go
all right to the 78 of you that took
part in this a Cobian tournament a games
oh all right
you